all right welcome to hannity news
breaking all over the place this
thursday night it was like watching a
train wreck in slow motion now despite
weeks of preparation even fake news cnn
admits it
cheat sheets uh with point font
and of course a compliant media mob
lobbing one softball question after
another
it uh still was not enough for joe biden
the frail the weak the cognitively
struggling clearly commander in chief or
is he
did not do well today to say the least
his long rambling answers his confusion
at points making no sense whatsoever at
other times he
became dazed and confused he just
stopped mid-sentence
just stopped mid-sentence stared into
space stared into the distance
yeah this is your president
and the other thing we're doing i might
add am i giving you too long an answer
because if you don't want the detail
no no but i mean i i don't know how much
detail you want about immigration
maybe i'll stop there infinity i believe
we should go back to a position of the
filibuster that existed just
when i came to the united states senate
120 years ago
so the best way to get something done if
you
if it holds near and dear to you that
you
like to be able to anyway
i'm we're going to get a lot done it is
the most pernicious thing
this makes jim crow look like jim eagle
i mean this is gigantic what they're
trying to do
my predecessor oh god i miss it
i know it's probably meant to be a joke
but it kind of seems like
joe's been in the senate 120 years ago
and by the way
who's jim eagle what was that about and
playing the race card keep in mind
on almost every question biden
referenced what appeared to be
numerous cheat sheets sprawled out on
the podium
in front of him at times reading
directly from his note cards
now i've been doing radio since 1987
here on the fox news channel since 1996.
never in my lifetime have i ever seen
anything like this before take a look
it used to be required for the
filibuster and i i had a card on this i
was going to give you the statistics but
you probably know them
uh that it used to be that uh
that from between 1917 and 1971 the
filibuster existed
there were a total of 58 motions
to break a filibuster all the things
that relate to infrastructure
we have somewhere i i asked the staff to
write it down for me and they did
not for this but for a longer discussion
we have somewhere in terms of
infrastructure
we have we rank 13th globally in
infrastructure
our enemies are watching this is
embarrassing
have you ever seen an american president
rely on a book of
cheat sheets before to ever answer a
simple
question at a press conference it is
pathetic it's embarrassing and let's be
clear here
the compliant media mob was not exactly
throwing joe
any any tough curveballs they were
incredibly polite and kind
and well we'll let you decide
how far are you willing to go to achieve
those promises that you made to the
american people
the perception of you that got you
elected as a moral
decent man is the reason why a lot of
immigrants are coming to this country
and entrusting you with unaccompanied
minors
republican legislatures across the
country are working to pass
bills that would restrict voting
particularly democrats fear
impacting minority voters and young
voters the very people who helped to get
you
elected in november at john lewis's
funeral president barack obama said he
believed the filibuster was a relic
of the jim crow era do you agree
of course joe didn't take any questions
from our own peter ducey not a shock
there naturally none of the other
reporters even dared to
ask about the wind knocking joe biden
down
three times climbing up air force one
the stairs there
the wind knocked him over nobody asked
him about
his struggles cognitively
or the bizarre scandal swirling around
zero experience hunter biden
involving an illegally obtained firearm
and potential cover-up
using biden's secret service detail
connections we'll have more on that in a
moment
and of course there were plenty of
questions about ending the filibuster so
the left can ram through their radical
agenda
biden responding by calling the
filibuster racist
oh we'll tell you in a minute how many
times democrats used it take a look
president barack obama said he believed
the filibuster was a relic of the jim
crow era
do you agree yes if not why not abolish
it if it's a relic of the jim crow era
successful electoral politics is the art
of the possible
let's figure out how we can get this
now democrats joe's party joe's pals
joe's friends
they used the filibuster over 250 times
last year
uh so joe was it racist when democrats
were using it
by the way the same joe biden that
partnered with the former klansmen to
stop the integration of public schools
really joe i guess biden was just
following al sharpton's lead
because al sharpton recently accused oh
the two senators
that said they believe in keeping the
filibuster mansion and cinema
of racism if they don't kill off the
filibuster
that joe is now calling racist well they
used it 250 times joe
are you calling your fellow democrats
racist we need answers
and meanwhile during a few softball
questions about the crisis
on the southern border biden of course
took no responsibility
and just blamed donald trump and in
doing so he told
one lie after another lie after another
lie
everything we're watching unfolding at
the southern border
can all be traced back to his decisions
he ended the stay in mexico policy he
stopped border wall construction
he's the one that brought back catch and
release he's building the new cages the
plastic cages for kids
that are on top of each other and now
infecting
1500 people take a look 28 increase in
children to the border in my
administration 31
in the last year of in 2019 before the
pandemic
in the trump administration it happens
every single solitary year
there is a significant increase in the
number of people coming to the border
in the winter months of january february
march
that happens every year so we're
building back up the capacity
that should have been maintained and
built upon
that trump dismantled it's going to take
time
just like the lie that the wind caused
joe biden to trip three times
going up the stairs to air force one
what he just said is a lie
no joe this does not happen every year
no it's not seasonal as you are claiming
last month border patrol they
intercepted over a hundred thousand
individual that is triple what it was
in february of last year triple in the
middle of a pandemic
now americans are getting covered from
undocumented
illegal immigrants entering the country
if they die joe who do you blame
thousands of migrants have tested
positive for coven 19.
many are then released into the united
states they haven't even been tested at
all
a record number of unaccompanied
migrants are expected at the border this
year
they're expecting a 20-year record and
it's all because joe biden dismantled
the policies of donald trump that were
working on the border
and of course he urged the migrants to
come in mass to seek asylum
did it on the campaign trail one of the
few times he spoke
but of course these weren't the only
lies from biden he also lied about
regular talks with senate republicans
that's a lie
he lied about trump's tax plan another
lie he lied about china and
by the way that was embarrassing with
his own secretary of state
getting lectured and then apologizing to
the communist chinese on the issue of
human rights uh like the genocide that's
going on there that they should have
confronted and we can go
on and on but really is anybody
surprised this is a guy known for
plagiarizing speeches
and just making stuff up and this is why
it's so important that the media gain
access
to yes what are overcrowded immigration
facilities the new cages built for kids
and it's now at a breaking point with
real human beings
stacked on top of each other in plastic
cages but according to joe
there will only be transparency when
he's good and ready not now when he's
good and ready
take a look will you commit to allowing
journalists to have access to the
facilities
that are overcrowded moving forward
i will commit when my plan very shortly
is underway to let you have access to
not just them but
other facilities as well
be able to have access to the facilities
we've obviously
been allowed to be inside one but we
haven't seen
the facilities in which children are
packed
together to really give the american
people a chance to see that will you
commit to transparency on this
i will commit to transparency and as
soon as i am in a position to be able to
implement what we're doing
right now you'll have full access to
everything
once we get this thing moving just to be
clear how soon will that be mr president
i don't know to be clear
let's be clear let me tell you what this
means a gag order
on people that work on the border
they're not allowed to talk to the press
you have to go through washington and
literally the media it's a blackout the
no access whatsoever to translate
we'll let you in the facilities when the
crisis is over
that is not transparency that's called a
cover-up when one reporter politely
challenged biden on the ongoing crisis
yeah as typical with this guy come on
man
well come on man you take cocaine before
this interview
come on are you a junkie come on man you
got very agitated
take a look is what's happening inside
acceptable to you and when is this going
to be fixed
that's a serious question right is it
acceptable to me come on
come on man here's the deal at least he
didn't
ask her if she was a junkie meanwhile
biden became so agitated when a reporter
asked him a simple question about
whether he plans to run for re-election
watch this
my plan is to run for re-election that's
my expectation
you also just made some news by saying
that you are going to run for
re-election
i said that is my expectation so is that
a yes that you are running for
re-election
look i i don't know where you guys come
from man i've never been able to travel
i'm a great respecter of fate i've never
been able to plan four and a half
three and a half years ahead for certain
and if you do if you do
run will vice president harris be on
your ticket i would fully expect that to
be the case she's doing a great job
she's a great partner
she's a great partner and do you believe
you'll be running against former
president trump
oh come on i don't even think about i
don't i have no idea
okay there you have it he won't even
commit to a second term
i don't know is he going to make it
through the first term
less than three months into the job and
it appears he's already looking for a
way out
by the way who can blame him joe biden
sad to say is obviously not
up for this job just the facts
now even fake news cnn admitted yeah
he's been prepping
for a single press conference and he has
at most
one item let's see all friday saturday
sunday no events off monday no events
one event tuesday
meet with a sports team wednesday
practice practice practice look at the
cnn reporter
this report quote biden has been getting
ready for days to face the white house
press
corps according to multiple people a
competent president should not need to
prep for days
on end to answer simple questions
this is the hardest job in the world a
commanding
24 7 job ask yourself
is joe biden in your view the american
people
up to the job to perform well even in a
press conference
after practicing for days what is he
capable of doing
anything because honestly we now need to
ask who's really running the show at
1600 pennsylvania
avenue is it vice president harris is it
chief of staff ron klain is it schumer
is it pelosi
is it barack obama uh is it susan rice
because it's certainly not the frail the
weak and the cognitively struggling guy
that we all witness today
if joe biden's not capable of doing the
job
he shouldn't be in the job so much is at
stake
our enemies are watching